foreign
world two Fields have emerged as pillars
of digital landscape cyber security and
cloud computing both The crucial roles
in shipping our digital infrastructure
and protective sensitive information
understanding their importance and
difference is essential for individuals
and organizations seeking to navigate
the complex Realm of the technology so
here I am with another video of Simply
loan that will help you gain perspective
toward building your career in any of
the two most booming field of this
decade but before we begin with the
video if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them interesting please
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you did also
hit the Bell icon to get notified
whenever we drop a new video let's have
a look at what we are going to discuss
in this video we'll start this video
with a crisp introduction to cyber
security and cloud computing moving
ahead we'll explain the reasons for
choosing cyber security and cloud
computing as your future career will
also discuss the salaries in both the
Domi and finally we'll let you know how
simply learned can help you make a
career in any of these fields so let's
start this video with cyber security
cyber security serves as a protective
shield for your digital information
shielding it from the reach of hackers
and various threats this involves
implementing multiple measures such as
establishing robbers passwords deploying
firewalls employing reliable antivirus
software and regularly updating security
protocol by adhering to good cyber
security practices you not only create a
safer online environment but also
proactively defend against the
unauthorized access viruses malware and
the potential compromise of your
personal information on the other hand
cloud computing revolutionizes data
storage and access by leveraging
scalable flexible infrastructure over
the Internet it enables seamless
collaboration optimization of operations
and Innovation opportunities for
business with secure and reliable remote
servers the cloud ensures accessible and
efficient data processing reducing costs
and enabling Dynamic scalability
embracing cloud computing and Powers
organizations to stay competitive in
this digital era leveraging Advanced
Technologies and transformative
Solutions talking about the reasons to
learn cyber security there are many
reasons to make a career in this field
the first one is increasing demand for
cyber security export the demand for
professionals specialized in cyber
security is experiencing rapid growth
with an estimated 32 percent job
increase from 2018 to 2028. this report
came out from the U.S Bureau of Labor
Statistics opportunities for
professional development fortunately the
field of cyber Security offers abundant
opportunities for career Advance as a
highly specialized skill you can
continuously learn to grow while working
in this field diverse range of Market
applications a career in cyber security
allows you to apply expertise across
various Industries leveraging your
passion and skills in different sector
the high demand for cyber security
positions translates into lucrative
career opportunities with companies
offering competitive salaries according
to glassdo the average salary of a cyber
security expert in India is
approximately 12 lakh per annum and in
the United States it's around 87 000
annually accompanied by additional cash
benefits so these reasons are why cyber
security is considered one of the safest
and highest paying jobs in the current
IT industry if you are among the
numerous users of Google's free services
such as Gmail sheets photos and Google
Docs so you are already utilizing their
Cloud infrastructure the multiple
reasons to choose a career in cloud
computing include developer flexibility
one of the critical advantages of cloud
computing is the flexibility it offers
to Developers Cloud developers can work
from anywhere and access the same
resources as their company headquarters
counterpart increase job opportunity
there's a high demand for cloud
developers driven by the growing need
for cloud-based solution cloud computing
has enhanced the reliability and speed
of the internet making information more
accessible increasing productivity and
keeping up with the latest technological
advancements this has resulted in a
search of job opportunities in the field
of cloud computing accompanied by
potential for higher salaries it's a
challenging field cloud computing can be
challenging to master due to its
novelity and Rapid Evolution however it
can be a rewarding career choice with
the right motivation and effort new
creative salary the salary of a cloud
developer depends on their experience
and skills a proficient Cloud developer
earns around 9 lakh seventy five
thousand dollars per year with
additional perks in India and the same
Cloud developer in the United States can
go up to 95 000 per year with additional
cash benefits depend depending on the
company so these are the reasons one
should consider a career in the field of
cloud compute there are several ways to
master both cyber security and cloud
computing but the best way to master any
technology is by getting a certification
simplylearn offers a wide variety of
certifications in different fields for
cyber security we have the post graduate
program in cyber security this
postgraduate program in cyber security
is designed to equip you with the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of cyber security
this cyber security program aims to help
you stay ahead of the latest cyber
security trends
key features of this program simply
learn postgraduate certificate master
classes from MIT faculty featuring
modules from mitscc and EC accounts
access to certified ethical hacking kit
with 25 plus Hands-On projects and many
so this cyber security certification
program begins with introductory level
skills and then progresses to Advanced
cyber security technology this program
covers all the essential skills you will
need to become an expert in the field of
cyber security cyber security is one of
the top concerns of businesses today in
any industry from securing data to
anticipating cyber Tech and placing
Enterprise word safeguards to prevent
them employers worldwide are
increasingly looking for qualified cyber
Security Professionals to join for cloud
computing we have the postgraduate
program in cloud computing the
postgraduate program in cloud computing
designed in collaboration with Caltech
ctme helps you become an Azure AWS and
gcp Expo this in-depth cloud computing
certification course lets you master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to become a cloud expert
benefits of this postgraduate program
includes Caltech ctme postgraduate
certificate enrollment and simply learns
job assist receive up to 30 CEUs from
Caltech ctme simply learns job assist
help you get noticed by top hiring
companies attend master classes from
caltex ctm instructors live virtual
classes led by industry experts Hands-On
projects and integrated lab online
convocation by Caltech ctme program
director for t plus Hands-On project and
integrated Labs caltex etm is circle
membership and many more you can also
fast track your career with this cloud
computing certification and its in-depth
course curriculum which covers the key
concepts of azure Amazon web services
and Google Cloud platform and services
such as AWS Lambda Amazon S3 Azure app
services and menu this program also
covers the essential skills to become an
expert in cloud computing and you can
consider this program because it
provides you with a certification for
from Caltech ctm a well-reputed
university in the United States in short
if you have a genuine interest in
technology data security and protecting
systems from cyber threats a career in
cyber security can be a good fit for you
similarly cloud computing might be the
right path if you are fascinated by
Cloud Technologies virtualization and
managing large-scale Data Systems so
before we end this video let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their career hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years
old and last year iobscure was simply
learned postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course the
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course be a learner first
well that's a wrap on cyber security or
cloud computing which is better as a
career we hope you found this video
informative and helpful by now you
should understand which career option
out of these two is the right choice for
you if you are interested in learning
more about different Technologies there
are plenty of resources available at
simply loan you can also check out our
website for more information on
different certifications so thank you
for watching and we'll see you next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you